[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday
tomorrow marks one year since a united
states airstrike
killed iranian general qasim suleimani a
top iranian commander is now warning of
quote
severe revenge for the attack meantime
an american who was held prisoner in
iran is giving his first televised
interview since his release
in an exchange as an exchange prisoner
shie
wong tells margaret brennan the incoming
biden administration
should focus on freeing other americans
held by iran
this is a birthday gift my son has drawn
um
that's a great picture nice work it's
all by
me after three and a half years of
separation
princeton scholar xie wong's best
birthday present was
time spent with his wife wah and their
son xiaofan
how old are you seven seven
when i came back when we had the first
meeting he recognized me instantly and
that was a very touching moment
his son was just a toddler when shie was
imprisoned in iran on fabricated charges
of espionage
[Music]
says he's just a scholar and targeted
because he's american
ministry of intelligence interrogator
told me clearly that they need me as a
spy
to convict me so that they can do a deal
with the united states
your captor explicitly told you that's
what they were
doing very explicitly yes and you're not
the first american
and you can be assured you're not the
last american
to be in uranium jail in december 2019
president trump swapped a jailed iranian
scientist for shii
do you think iran got what it wanted
they didn't get
everything they had hoped for they
wanted the money they told me they
wanted
the their frozen asset being released to
them
at least three other americans are still
being held
she a met one siamak namazi in prison
president-elect biden wants to try out
diplomacy with iran to tackle its
nuclear program
but expert suzanne maloney says that
shouldn't be the only issue
there needs to be negotiations around
the nuclear issue
but that doesn't mean subordinating the
other sets of concerns particularly the
lives of americans who are held in
iranian prisons
she is urging biden to make returning
the americans
his first priority without their return
no deal with iran
xie is urging president-elect biden not
to lift financial pressure off iran
the biden team has offered to rejoin the
iran nuclear deal which would lift
sanctions worth billions and lay the
groundwork for future talks
the biden team tells cbs news it will
also work to reunite americans
for cbs this morning saturday i'm
margaret brennan in washington